Hello. Welcome to Michael's Better Business English.
This month, we're looking at a very important technique: how to be positive.
Here, there are two key issues to be careful of.
First: Attitude.
Do you have a can't-do attitude or can-do attitude?
Often, Japanese business people tend to focus on problems,...
...difficulties or risks in meetings.
This can have a bit of a negative impression on other people.
Other cultures such as Western cultures prefer a can-do approach.
Rather than focusing on problems or risks, what are the solutions or opportunities?
Secondly, use positive language to be positive and show a can-do attitude.
Try using not, plus a positive word instead of a negative word.
For example: "This quarter, sales were bad."
Better: "This quarter, sales were not so good."
Still the same basic meaning but a more positive feeling.
Also, try balancing a negative point with a positive one.
For example: "Sales last year were not so good"...
..."but this year, they're looking much better."
And finally, try to use more positive words in your speech.
Words like successful, excellent, wonderful, great or exciting.
This will help give a positive impression to the mind of the listener.
So, use these techniques and you can be positive too.
Thank you and good luck.